leur téléphone est devenu l'unique lien
avec leurs maris membres du commando
azoff non il me demande de lui envoyer
des photos du soleil de la nature parce
que ça fait un mois qu'il ne voit rien
de méchant destin
retranché dans les ruines de la
métallurgie d'azov talent à l'est de
mario paul les soldats tentent de
survivre dans des conditions de plus en
plus insoutenable ils se partagent un
verre d'eau pas toujours potable toutes
les 5 ou 6 heures
un manque d'eau de nourriture mais aussi
de moyens médicaux après le bombardement
de l'hôpital militaire de lusine les
risques de septicémie sont forts même
pour les blessures légères
mon époux aussi et blessé des mines des
rangs les jambes amputées donc reste
allongé et les autres qui ont un brin
fonctionnel aident leurs camarades
annan a que 15 minutes toutes les deux
semaines pour parler à son mari
c'est donc surtout par message qu'elle
communique avec lui ce sont ses derniers
messages
lui est membre du régiment azoff depuis
2000 14 basée à mario paul son bataillon
devient rapidement l'une des dernières
poches de résistance au sein de la ville
en cause je ne pouvais pas rester les
bras croisés sans rien faire
j'ai envoyé un message à le garage à
bruxelles et on n'a pas ça et elle m'a
dit et si on allait voir le pape
même constat pour katarina épouse de
l'un des commandos du régiment très
présent sur les réseaux sociaux ah ouais
la situation un hostel s'est dégradée
c'est devenu critique nous avons donc
réfléchi un moyen pour les sauver
c'est auprès des dirigeants
internationaux qu'elle espère obtenir un
soutien pour l'évacuation urgente des
soldes asos talent après le vatican et
la france elle envisage de se déplacer
en grande bretagne aux états unis et en
chine